in today's buddy check report
oncologists are hopeful but measured
about the results of a new study from
the journal of clinical oncology women
diagnosed with estrogen receptor or ER
positive tumors continue to experience
breast cancer recurrence and death for
as long as 30 years after initial
diagnosis so researchers examined the
lifetime benefits and harm of staying on
their medications long term to prevent
the disease from returning the new
computer model study shows these
treatments could reduce the risk of
Dying Years Later local surgeon Dr
noblock cautions though what works for
one patient doesn't work for everyone
we need to add it to other information
that we have and we need to use it to
stimulate us to think differently at
times but there's rarely a time when one
study changes everything that we do
well one thing that we do know that
works catching breast cancer early
through a mammogram or self-exam if you
don't have insurance and you need a
mammogram or other breast health
services you can reach out to the red
rose program at St Rose Dominican you
can get a preventative exam totally free
with no need of medical insurance or
proof of residency details are on our
buddy check page at 8newsnow.com Cherry
is just so important